hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
from Monday September 11th 2017 what's
going on how are ya how's it going how's
it going more hurricanes more hurricanes
and this is a 17th anniversary of the
attacks on the World Trade Center the
Pentagon and then the one that went down
in Pennsylvania you know I mean Jesus
Christ what is going on this week it's
just all gloom and friggin doom you know
I was sitting there watching the news
with Nia right and they're showing
highlights of this was it hurricane
earth say is what is it Jim Irsay was
coming into [ __ ] Miami right and
there's some [ __ ] you know white dude
out there of course but you know it's
gonna come down they show like five
white people out there and Nia literally
said to me she goes what is wrong with
white people I had to laugh I was like
you know oh we for the most part we grew
up and cul-de-sacs there's no excitement
there's no drive-bys there's no you know
cops beating you up for no reason
generally speaking you know it's gonna
hey knock it off over there straight up
I know your father you know it's kind of
like that so I guess you know hurricane
comes around you what you need a story
[ __ ] you need a story I have no idea why
I came up with a hacky eighties joke
though about [ __ ] the Hurricanes it's
let's it's why don't they have all the
people stand where the reporters are
because the reporters never die they're
always standing in the [ __ ] middle of
the [ __ ] I don't know how I don't know
how these news agencies know exactly
where to [ __ ] stand but somehow they
stand just enough in the [ __ ] I don't
buy it
I don't buy it I'm she has one of them
died yet you know I don't [ __ ] I mean
how the [ __ ] do that you know Jesus
pills spit it out sorry I flew today
once I'm already done but once I fly it
just and I'll breathe in that [ __ ]
pressurized air up there I mean it's
[ __ ] inevitable if you stand out
inside in a [ __ ] hurricane
something's gonna fall on top e it's bad
enough I
I love when they sit there and they tell
these people you need to evacuate you
got to get out of there and it's like
and go where to my summer home don't you
remember the [ __ ] banks left half
this country upside down in their
[ __ ] house it's [ __ ] unreal I
don't understand like where these people
are supposed to go like weird where do
they go everybody just goes north and
sits in a [ __ ] Waffle House for 3-4
days all the hotels get bought up and if
you don't have money what do you what
are you supposed to do anyways at least
it was knocked down to a category three
man I read some [ __ ] you know that's
some horrible [ __ ] about Houston that's
still going on now there's all mold and
there's all and you know you don't need
to listen to this you see it all [ __ ]
day this is all just gloom and doom all
[ __ ] misery here so why don't I go to
something positive I actually friended
the podcast one of the great drummers of
all time Steven Adler he sent me this
thing he's got a they're doing something
for Ronnie James Dio on October 6th at
6:30 p.m. bull for Ronnie celebrity
Christ my eyes are going celebrity
bowling tournament all right now [ __ ]
I'm not gonna be able to read this I
can't okay here we go gotta love that
you can enlarge it I wish I could do
this to the world man I have to get
glasses why won't I just give in to the
fact that I need glasses all right
October 6 2017 6:30 p.m. celebrity
bowling tournament Bowl for Ronnie I
don't for God's sake Steven where is it
gonna be it out pins balling Center 1 2
6 5 5 Ventura Boulevard Studio City
California 9 1 604 go down there it's
for a great cause and you know have
yourself a White Russian you know and
tell Donny to shut the [ __ ] up okay and
I'll be down there for a great cause
alrighty there you go I'll put up a link
I'm gonna post the whole flyer on the
Monday morning thing I'm a jig there's
another guy got the TV on there am on my
Twitter account there's a guy standing
out there
Jesus Christ standing out there in the
[ __ ] rain like the video al Roker's
out there
how many hurricanes is that poor bastard
stood out and now it's going up to Tampa
then it looks like it's gonna go right
over the Florida Gators football stadium
somehow die around [ __ ] Macon Georgia
is that what this says is that the
trajectory I don't know what anyways so
I was in Mississippi flew into [ __ ]
Mississippi on Thursday night and I
missed the entire New England Patriots
game and from what I've heard as a
Patriots fan was probably better to just
land and find out that they got this
[ __ ] kicked out of him really just kind
of in the fourth quarter of though I
mean it was kind of a shootout with no
[ __ ] defense as far as I could tell
yeah the Chiefs are all excited doing
[ __ ] cartwheels because they let up
[ __ ] 27 points I don't know what
they're so [ __ ] excited about but I
will tell you as a Patriots fan I'm
pretty [ __ ] happy I'm gonna tell you
why I want to tell you why because I
don't like the [ __ ] worst thing ever
is when before you even start the season
those [ __ ] hacks on the sports shows
go you know they talk about your team
look good they go right they start doing
that [ __ ] so before the [ __ ] season
already starts you already got that
[ __ ] monkey on your back every
[ __ ] fat douche who never got picked
in gym class coming in with his [ __ ]
loafers and his sweaters waddling into
your locker room just trying to rip the
team apart and just adding just
distraction so right out of the gate we
[ __ ] lose all of that is gone and
then immediately they go oh oh oh whoa
wait a minute wait a minute
remember were you saying Tom Brady isn't
it after his last game was the greatest
without a doubt of all-time now were the
exact same people one [ __ ] game later
saying he's too old so I'm loving that
I'm loving all of that what would you
know I would actually love if we lost
next week too but then they would have
all this you know what's the time
they'd have to deal with that so I'm
hoping you know they win the next three
four they lose another one four and two
then they're five just nobody's paying
attention
no they treat us like the Indianapolis
Colts man when they were 13 and oh and
nobody said [ __ ] for whatever [ __ ]
reason which is really a reoccurring
thing with the Indianapolis Colts no
matter what they do hearing aids in the
[ __ ] helmets [ __ ] pump and crowd
noise in tank in the final third of a
season to get Andrew Luck stealing the
Patriots offense [ __ ] being on the
Rules Committee changing the rules of
passing and on and on and [ __ ] on
right going 13 and oh nobody's saying
[ __ ] oh they're just a bunch of country
boys out there we won't pay attention to
him I love it I love that we I mean I
hate our [ __ ] defense but I haven't
liked our defense since we won our first
three I think ever since then we've
always been like you know well we're
gonna score you were gonna score 35
we're gonna score 38 I always just I
just kind of feel like we've been like
that for too long and occasionally we've
brought we've brought in a shutdown
corner like a Revis
oh then taalib whatever the [ __ ] his
name was who was here for like a year or
two he was [ __ ] great but then all of
a sudden like yeah okay now I want to
get paid they're like yeah so anyways
yeah so I just I watched a little bit of
the highlights I mean when you give up
an 85-yard touchdown in your corner like
[ __ ] lets the guy go by him because
he thinks he's got help over the top and
the guy just isn't there I mean I really
don't think that's the chief kicking our
ass as much as that's just horrible
defense you know what I mean I would say
though that that guy running for like
six thousand yards against us is
definitely a concern but you know what
are we supposed to win it every [ __ ]
year
you know I'm alright with it I love it I
love it so there we go so now what now
what we go 11 and 5 they'll fix it but I
don't know you know we do we always
[ __ ] have guys and then they make the
Pro Bowl and then they ask for more
money then we let him go and then we got
to build it back up again so we'll see
it is definitely towards the end of Tom
Brady's career you know I don't know how
it could have gone any [ __ ] better
you know what are you gonna tie me with
the fist you know you know why so many
people flipped out about that aside from
the fact that they hate the Patriots
it's that's how people that's how most
people live their lives you know they
take one loss and they just pack it in
and I'm including a lot of Patriots fans
you know those [ __ ] you can never
listen to those sports shows because
even like the people who call in you
know they always use words like
concerned okay right now I'm really
concerned about our past defense on dirt
towns are you what are you concerned
about as if you're like you're a part of
the coaching staff and if it doesn't
work you're gonna get fired you have to
put your house up for sale and reload
you relocate your kids once again what
exactly are you concerned about but
congratulations the Chiefs I've actually
I've always liked the Chiefs I just
always watch those Super Bowl highlights
and that one with Hank Stram you know 64
toss power trap was always like that one
of the great ones just sitting there
laughs and his [ __ ] balls off and
everybody loved that back then but now
if they had that audio he'd have to
issue an apology to the Minnesota
Vikings and Bud Grant in the family and
all that [ __ ] but so anyways I was
flying back from Alabama and so the only
football games I was able to catch I
watched the Green Bay Seattle game which
I know Seattle fans hate because they
they definitely seemed like they were
getting the short end of the stick
certainly on that phantom punch exaction
which I didn't see I just saw the replay
of it of course it happened on a [ __ ]
pick six always fun to watch Pete
Carroll Luke blow a [ __ ] gasket but
that guy is a great coach and that's
that's a great defense you know what I
mean the [ __ ] Legion to do you know
bleeding a boom sorry boom right in your
ass with the steroids
[ __ ] all you guys if you're gonna bring
up every [ __ ] goddamn time Jesus
Christ we Bend a card in [ __ ] New
England I'm [ __ ] trashing everybody
I'm doing research on all your [ __ ]
teams and I'm gonna do what you guys do
every [ __ ] time you give me [ __ ]
about my I'm [ __ ] fine I'm gonna
[ __ ] look in the corners of your
franchise Jesus Christ like 30% of that
[ __ ] team tested pause defense tested
positive for [ __ ] steroids and
they're still just talking about how
great they are unbelievable oh that's
another Colts won that guy caught the
[ __ ] allegedly deflated ball which
was never [ __ ] proven he's never
[ __ ] proven yet Tom still got [ __ ]
suspended everybody's basically paying
the price for the under suspension of
Ray Rice I think when they go into Roger
Goodell how psyched we see that the
Patriots lost after they those barstool
guys had that hilarious t-shirt of him
just like a [ __ ] clown is there
anything better than just cones say he's
a [ __ ] clown all your accomplishments
just go right out the window that
[ __ ] guy Roger Goodell makes thirty
million dollars a year thirty million
dollars if you can catch him walk into
his car and you go you're a [ __ ]
clown I'm telling you as much as he has
thirty million dollars probably seven
sixteen after taxes it bugs him he's
gonna be thinking about it when he's
drinking his little duckies coffee in
the morning [ __ ] is that guy to call me
a clown talking himself you know when
he's putting his suit on he's got the
jacket tie and shirt he looks like one
of those guys he gets everything on he
puts the pants on last Cloutier he has
his shoes on with the [ __ ] socks and
the sock garters you got I'm talking
himself he's just in the nut in the
[ __ ] knot right there and then in the
mirror so anyway so I watched that game
and the defense's looked great in those
[ __ ] games and and now I got the I
got the cowboys and Giants in the
background I did watch the MotoGP race I
just watched the the big boys I didn't
get to watch MotoGP three or two but
what a [ __ ] race how about Marc
Marquez just saying you know divisio is
just like a man I went
I'm gonna take the [ __ ] points Marc
Marquez is like [ __ ] that [ __ ] that I'm
going for the victory for you guys
didn't watch motorcycle racing it was
raining out and they still race they
don't quite go as fast but they were
going like over a hundred and fifty
miles an hour and the [ __ ] rain on
each other's asses and this guy what the
[ __ ] was his name he started the race he
[ __ ] shot right up beside in the
first place what the [ __ ] is be able to
pee I can't I don't I'm new to the sport
I don't know all their names
so anyways no did it was that guy bill
why don't you just look this [ __ ] up so
you can talk you know what happened you
just can't remember the [ __ ] names
what was the guy's name Larry legend is
that the guy who [ __ ] shut up and
first before he [ __ ] wiped out
there's more goddamn accidents today or
yesterday I should say when they were
racing and uh anyways everything that
Formula One needs
MotoGP has it was a race right down to
the end and [ __ ] Marc Marquez said
[ __ ] this I'm going for the points cuz
if he got to 25 he was gonna be tied
with divisio so he passed him on the
[ __ ] last lap or second-to-last lap
and then held them off you know was it
was some Phil Mickelson [ __ ] you know
I'm not gonna [ __ ] you know just try
to get back out on the fairway I'm gonna
try to put it in the hole and then I'm
gonna for putt and walk away with sweaty
tits I mean that's what this man did but
basically on a motorcycle so that was
very enjoyable but let's get down let's
talk about going down south now that the
Patriots season is evidently over and
Tom Brady is over the hill
you know the Atlanta Falcons won today
and the New England Patriots lost the
exact opposite thing that happened the
last time so there you go I don't know
what that means I'm sure Atlanta Falcon
fans if they could switch you know the
results with the Patriots I think they
would you know but evidently the [ __ ]
football sky is falling you know I
[ __ ] hate about fantasy football that
is literally taken over like you said
like in the sports pages they used to
just have they would have like the
leaders it was Sun was really easy to
find the leaders you could collect
football cards and [ __ ] I used to know
so much more about the game I don't know
anybody's [ __ ] name anymore anytime
you go to any sort of website
where they have like fantasy when you
want to look at stats it's all this
fantasy football [ __ ] get this guy and
your team Peyton Manning's [ __ ]
advertising that stuff I don't know
should I just give in should I just give
I don't want to I don't want to do that
[ __ ] I don't want to have somebody on a
team actually I don't really hate any
other team in the NFL do I hate any a
team
I hate Jimmer say that's it that's the
only person I don't like you know
there's certain people that act like
[ __ ] idiots in the league that I
don't particularly care for but that I
don't hate the team you know here's
another classic the Cowboys are probably
gonna beat the Giants because this is
what the Cowboys and Giants do the
Cowboys win in the beginning part of the
year and then the Giants always [ __ ]
lose and in the end they come back
around and they do the same thing down
in New York so time to move on from Eli
he only steps up in every [ __ ] big
moment in January his entire career I
think it's time to get rid of him
because he [ __ ] up in September you
know I didn't even lemon look this [ __ ]
up there that Ezekiel Elliott guy play
seems to me what's weird is they threw
out his case in the real world but it's
like in the NFL you need less burden of
proof Elliott Cowboys is out his [ __ ]
name
Elliott Cowboys to play is he playing
judge grants temporary restraining order
request for Dallas Cowboys running back
probably from that psycho with that
person's semen like a psycho okay
Ezekiel Elliott really makes you I've
been out of the loop alright so you
played that's good that's good because
the clown was gonna over suspend them a
look at this the NFL is back and so are
the 15 reasons it's a complete disaster
hey how about those Los Angeles Rams
coming back wearing the Lamar Lundy
[ __ ] blue-and-white the fearsome
foursome Merlin Olsen rosey Grier was it
Lamar Lundy I always forget him
what's-his-face there I could never name
all four of them I always end up
forgetting one I always remember Merlin
Olsen rosey Grier of Jesus Christ the
coolest one of them all Deacon Jones and
it was it Lamarr Lundy Lamar Lamar Lundy
is this even a podcast is this do you
guys listen to me [ __ ] yeah there you
go right Lamar Lundy was he a Steeler
was Abraham he was here Ram Lamar Lord
Ram's fearsome force am i right I got it
all right so anyways let's get let's
let's I'm not watching TV anymore now
I'm focused now I'm focused oh is he
like driving him in what's he got his
second in eight eight oh nine to go
in the third quarter Eli calling a
[ __ ] audible over the middle for a
first down moving the ball Cowboys fans
are all gonna be [ __ ] saying you need
to [ __ ] bench [ __ ] quarterback and
bring back Roger Staubach so we did the
the Horseshoe Casino in Mississippi I
had so much [ __ ] fun doing that
although it was just a part of the South
man that was just deep deep deep deep
south deep south hang a [ __ ] right
don't stop in Alabama keep going stop
right before you get the [ __ ]
Louisiana and it was just it was the
pace of the people down that was driving
me [ __ ] nuts
you know I ordered room service twice I
camp ordering water and they just
wouldn't bring it up to me so the second
time I said did you where's the glutton
is there a glass of water and she's like
well no I'm try and I'm like and and
that's what's on the tray just [ __ ]
walks out there's no oh I'm sorry I'll
go get you some it's like it wasn't on
the tray so then I go to use it like
nothing [ __ ] worked I go to use the
[ __ ] ironing board the ironing board
was [ __ ] up I was trying to make it
stand up it wouldn't stand up I had to
bend the piece back it wouldn't and then
I finally just had a [ __ ] meltdown
and I'm admitting this to the casino I
jumped up and down
and then I pulled this shark nose back
I felt bad afterwards and I tried to
bend it back but it's all [ __ ] up if
you wonder why it's [ __ ] up I finished
it off it was already [ __ ] up so if
you want to send me a bill I apologize
and then the next day me Dean and
bartnik drove over into Tuscaloosa to go
on we went to go see Alabama versus
Fresno State we had a great [ __ ] time
we met some people there some friends of
mine and they hooked us up we were and I
think this [ __ ] skybox no sunburn you
know it was a cupcake game who's kidding
who against Fresno State it was a day
game it's like I went but I have to go
back there again I want to go there a
night game when they play like Texas A&M
Mississippi or [ __ ] you know anybody
like LSU or some [ __ ] like that I want
to go back for that I want to sit in the
[ __ ] crowd the next time this was
like it was too nice it was awesome I
had a great time
but it was like I think I didn't get to
feel the crowd a little bit which was
perfect because I had a show that night
so I didn't drink I'm still not drinking
and I didn't get a sunburn so it worked
out for me but I feel like I kind of
went to a preseason game so we're
walking out of there and [ __ ] Joe
bartnik somehow found the one Russian
guy in Alabama and [ __ ] escalated
quickly you know bardick walks up to the
guy the guy I don't know how they got
into a conversation the guy said he was
somehow he said he he always heard his
talk and he meant said something to us
we waiting for the elevator the guy said
that he was Russian
so bar Nick's a huge Penguin's fan and
he goes Russian he goes hey you know
he's like Geno Malkin you have any
mocking right you like Malcolm the guys
like that he's like I like he's like I
let go veg kit and then he goes you like
infection and then he gets right in the
guy's face and he goes zero cops zero
cops he's like Ovechkin he goes and
starts doing the choking thing all right
Joe it had a couple of sarsaparilla
who's kidding no right so they [ __ ]
start going back and forth and the eat
Joe keeps giving him
[ __ ] the guy's gonna come on man it's a
team game and he goes a cup so how can
you like zero cups zero coupla keeps
acting like the guy's choking on a
[ __ ] dick and the Russian guys
getting mad
Jose [ __ ] around he's not seeing it
and the [ __ ] elevator cannot come
fast enough because it looks like it's
gonna escalate into a fight which you
know Joe bartnick and this Russian guy
was actually taller than Joe but he was
skinnier but you know he's also Russian
you know what I mean so you know you
know it's [ __ ] people they they be
they be think [ __ ] bitch-slapped
Hitler all the way back to [ __ ]
Berlin you know let people out of
prisons and say hey remember we threw
you in there for why don't you come out
and go do that to people who look like
this and that's what they did half of
them weren't bare feet I mean I know
it's a legend at this point but it's
pretty much [ __ ] true so now I'm
concerned cuz they're both Joe's like
whatever six for this guy's like six
five and I kept going Joe hey man hey
Joe
take it easy just kept going just kept
doing it and he's laughing at the gun
and I don't know what he just wasn't
seeing the guy getting mad so the guy
goes hey why don't we go around the
corner Joe's like hey let's go around
the corner and they walk around the
corner I'm like are they gonna go fight
and then then there was this awkward
little moment between him and me and
Dina stone sober like what the [ __ ]
so finally I just go to my buddy go is
this some stairs we can take cuz the
elevator was taking forever and he goes
yeah you know we can take the stairs so
we go to take the stairs and we're going
to walk out and the Russians guys like I
will take the stairs - now they were
walking down the stairs and it's just
like I couldn't separate him I couldn't
get him separated and I don't know what
happened by the end of it they were they
were like best of friends ready to go
drink some [ __ ] vodka we actually
left the game halfway through the fourth
quarter because we had to go do our show
but we wanted to go around and get a
picture in front of the Bear Bryant
statue and we actually got one in front
of the Nick Saban one there's one other
guy that nobody everybody always forgets
he's only won one championship but it
was pretty [ __ ] amazing
to go that I'm telling you if you if you
get a [ __ ] chance man everybody wants
to go to the ballparks all the baseball
parks they go to a [ __ ] Lambeau Field
in that type of [ __ ] which I understand
but you know all you guys who live in
pro football cities and in you know New
York Chicago all that Pro [ __ ] Boston
don't sleep on going to big-time college
football man I'm telling you SEC Big Ten
you got to go to the University of
Michigan you got to go to a horseshoe
and Ohio State you got to go to one of
them you just have to experience a
hundred thousand [ __ ] people going
absolutely [ __ ] nuts pick a good
rivalry game go on [ __ ] StubHub pay
through the nose go out there get
[ __ ] hammered go to the game and then
please tell me what you see in the NFL
because I don't think the NFL can near
nearly touches the excitement although
having said that how great is it that
it's [ __ ] football season this is
what always have all season goes by like
the summer you know what I mean like
every year in the summer of arcades May
we're going into May I'm really gonna
pay attention and try to enjoy and
remember like hey it's this summer we're
in the summer
let's [ __ ] enjoy this [ __ ] I still
feel that way even though I live out in
LA where it's summer all the [ __ ]
time right and every every [ __ ] year
Oh sudden it's just like September
alright and football season it's the
same thing like oh my god [ __ ]
football season it's like and great then
all of a sudden it's like it's the
playoffs and you're so focused on the
playoffs playoffs then all of a sudden
like it's that week between the
championship game and the Super Bowl you
like what the [ __ ] happened you so busy
putting money on the games and betting
on the [ __ ] games you don't realize
not only is there only one two teams
left there's only one game left and then
then we're [ __ ]
then what [ __ ] and then the panic
starts to set and then you think well at
least I got March Madness right at least
it got much madness and then I got the
hockey and the basketball playoffs and
then there's just a it's just you know
what it really is is just July it's that
one panic of July and end August the dog
days of baseball that you have to
[ __ ] deal with that's how I ended up
getting into [ __ ] I think Formula One
and all that [ __ ] just
with that then I totally got into it I
don't know I feel like I've been talking
in circles for like [ __ ] 25 minutes
what is this how many how many awful
minutes this has been 26 see that you
comedian long enough you can you can you
could sense time I had this feeling that
I've been bombing for 26 [ __ ] minutes
so I'll congratulations - everybody's
team who won this week including the
Chiefs not a [ __ ] and everybody who lost
it's only few no it's just one week
[ __ ] relax
25 days and no booze 25 days of knows
booze I'll tell you how well I'm doing
with no booze when I went out I went
through the duty-free and I saw that
Macallan mccallum rare cask black which
I'd never heard of and I'm like I am
[ __ ] buying that when I get bit when
I come back off the plane and when I got
off the plane I you know I think I flew
Delta out United on the way back so it
wasn't there but I was gonna buy it you
know I'm sitting that talked to myself
like I might done like I was actually
thinking on the plane today like I might
be done for good and then I came home
and I ordered these whiskey glasses and
I'm like well that's not a good sign
like if you just say I'm done with
heroin and then you go to Amazon or you
go to like syringe net you know and you
just order a bunch of [ __ ] drug
paraphernalia I guess as long as you
don't buy the drugs right eh I just Kate
officer I collect crack pipes okay can I
have them can I have my license back
please
but you're not gonna find any residue in
there so anyway I was actually thinking
on the plane I'm like yeah Mike what if
I just next year I turned 50 right and
I'm just done with the booze and then I
just become like this yoga pilates guy I
just go stink right Gordon Sumner I
become that [ __ ] guy you know I look
good for my age if I actually [ __ ]
did that through my 50s I would look
[ __ ] unbelievable
at 60 for a 60 year old you know and you
figured by then you know how
tanning beds are gonna be how good the
hair plugs are gonna be you know and I
bet I'll be microchip by then which I
can also have like the added viagra
option to it you know what I mean
I think I can stay in the game for
another ten years after that I don't
know what do you guys think have you
guys thought about the future you the
microchipped you full head of hair and
abs alright let me read some advertising
you know speaking of fantasy football
you know is the best thing about fantasy
football rather than sitting around
[ __ ] giving a [ __ ] to your divorce
buddy in your own [ __ ] living room
during your stupid draft why don't you
go to draftkings and try to make some
money so you can at least afford some
lotion week one is in the books but it's
not too late to get closer to the game
you love with draft kings one-week
fantasy football because of this site
right there draft kings this Sunday
draft kings is hosting a 100,000 dollar
pick'em contest that is totally free to
enter pick'em is the newest way to play
one-week fantasy football drafting yet
team is faster than ever
draft kings has organized players into
eight tiers all you have to do is select
one player from each tier do this is
like doing an 18 T's now if you pick it
perfectly you're telling me you win a
billion dollars that's what they're
saying
choose between public contests with big
cash prizes or private contents well you
can compete against a group draftkings
also has a beginner in casual contests
where you'll play against people of
similar skill level everybody wants to
go home with a ribbon the best part is
you get draft you get to draft a new
team each week without any commitment
[ __ ] it's open so get to draftkings.com
now and use promo code burr to play in
draft King draft Kings free contest with
$100,000 in total prizes this Sunday use
my promo code Burpee URR to play for
free this Sunday that's promo code bar
at draft kings.com eligibility
restrictions apply see draft kings
komm for details people try to have fun
with that
okay don't [ __ ] put your whole
mortgage on it alright okay here we go
where am I going where am I going frame
bridge everybody oh Jesus frame bridge
you know what's frame bridge is well
Jesus Christ it's the easiest way to
custom frame your favorite art and
photos without ever leaving your house
you fat [ __ ] with their simple online
ordering process you can order a fully
custom customized piece in minutes
here's how it works yeah you can fully
customize your dick pics somebody should
do one of you know those school pictures
with its with its it's the double shot
where it's you looking straight ahead
and then you looking up in the air you
got to do a dick pic version of that
here's how it works go to frame bridge
comm upload your photos from your
computer or directly from your Instagram
feed ladies or if you have a physical
item they'll provide secure prepaid
packaging so you can mail it in for free
preview your photos online in any frame
style choose your favorite or get free
help from their talented designers the
expert team at frame bridge will
customize what custom frame your item in
days not weeks or months and deliver
your finished piece directly to your
door ready to hang the best part instead
of hundreds you pay at a framing store
their prices start at just $39 all
shipping is free plus my listeners will
get 15% off their first order at frame
bridge comm when they use my code per
frame which even offers a happiness
guaranteed are you happy if for any
reason you aren't 100% satisfied with
your order they'll make it right give
your personal experience using frame
bridge comm oh I'll give it to you I've
never used it I keep saying I'm gonna
use it I keep taking pictures uploading
them to my computer's and then sticking
them on to hard drives that end up in
the back of my closet and then I sit
there and wonder what the [ __ ] happened
to him and I wish that I got some of
them framed so frame bridge you're like
the you're the website that got away you
know that chick I should have said a low
two you know taken in a bet
the site is easy the site the ease of
order and how shut up man okay get ready
get started today framing your photos
are art go to frame bridge calm and use
the promo code BRR
you'll save an additional 15% off your
first order just go to frame bridge calm
promo code BRR framing calm from promo
Cooper all right last lastly but not
leastly oh Jesus Christ would you look
who's back
would you look who's back ladies and
gentlemen stamps calm the original I
think these are the first people ever
advertised on my podcast stamp save you
time and money but you can use to create
because if you didn't use a stamp you'd
have to get in your car and [ __ ]
deliver it yourself right stamp save you
time and money but you can use to grow
your business I can mail any letter any
package using just my computer and
printer and the [ __ ] mailman comes
and picks it up avoid the hassle man I'm
going to the post office and mail
everything from postcards to envelopes
to packages domestic or international no
drugs create your stamps account in
minutes online with no equipment to
lease and no long term commitments click
print mail in you're done
unlike the post office stamps calm never
closes print postage for letters of
packages at your own convenience 24/7
buy and print official US postage for
any letter any package any class of mail
using your own computer and printer
stamps calm makes it easy they'll send
you a digital scale it automatically
calculates the exact postage stamps come
will even help you decide the best class
of mail based on your needs no need to
lease an expensive postage meter for the
last [ __ ] time I used an stop calm
any time I sent out my posters any time
I sell posters at the end of the show
I'm a [ __ ] if I can figure it out so
can you and right now like this very
many you too can enjoy the stamps
telecom service with a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale without long
term commitments go to stamps.com click
on the microphone stop the homepage and
type of bird stamp commenter per stamp
stock up never go to the post office
again alrighty there that is done that
is done so I'm actually toying with that
idea you know
no booze dun dun I don't know if I can I
don't know I understand why alcoholics
like they take it one day at a time cuz
she's just sitting there like I'm never
gonna do this not just today I'm just
not gonna do it today just not gonna do
it today you know sometimes you got to
do it though right you know your wife's
talking to you and you're sitting there
looking at her smiling a nod she's
thinking I love what he looks at me that
way he still loves me I can see it in
his eye and you're actually thinking
about that bottle of booze that you
bought are you gonna go out in the
garage like a [ __ ] degenerate sit
some dirty chair you don't give a [ __ ]
right pour that glass you set the bottle
down it touches the floor you hear it
echoing in your garage you know that
garage that's yours right that garage
that you made the decision you weren't
gonna be like these most of these guys
who let their wives not only take over
the house but also the garage right they
just fill it up with all this [ __ ] you
can't even get the [ __ ] car in there
that garage is yours you put up the
dartboard you get the kegerator that
sets you little [ __ ] tree fort you
know meat hose kit know you're a guy yet
you're still a child just cuz you can
grow a beard doesn't mean you're mature
all right
would you look at all these stars doing
these [ __ ] commercials now jesus
[ __ ] christ can you leave something
on the bone for this struggling actor
can't you just do a [ __ ] a Dover and
Guam like you used to
anyways I want to redo my [ __ ] garage
again okay I got it I gotta add
something else in there I got to add a
[ __ ] you know now that I never have my
truck in there you know I put it in
storage so I kind of flip-flop and
everything like that with the new car
and then the old car I haven't driven my
truck in like two weeks man I miss it I
got to do that something I got to have
the garage with the [ __ ] Rome above
it you just have to have it that's what
it is you know
and then which you have a [ __ ]
prenuptial agreement that if we get
divorced I get the garage and the room
above it and you cannot [ __ ] evict me
that will be mine and you will get the
[ __ ] house but you know something
[ __ ] bills people but I just don't
feel safe with you being out there oh
they cry their way into getting that too
you know I swear to God I wonder if
anybody like when a hurricanes coming
and if they're in an unhappy marriage
like what's going through their mind you
just sitting there with your wife you
know she doesn't know that you bought a
boat that you tied to the back of the
house a little [ __ ] rowboat you know
you can't see it you convince her to try
to ride out the storm when water comes
in you like see you later
oh Jesus bill alright let's get to the
[ __ ] questions this week I apologize
what do you you know what I don't
apologize I don't apologize for [ __ ]
making up [ __ ] I'm making up [ __ ] man
what the [ __ ] you want from me
alright booze line ups booze line ups
did I talk about everything I want to
talk about first before I get into this
[ __ ] let's see here Steven Adler Ronnie
James Alabama verse Fresno State
Mississippi horseshoe ironing board oh
yeah when I was waiting for the [ __ ]
car to come around I was standing out
front of a hotel going I'm never coming
to this [ __ ] state again I was so
[ __ ] everything was going so goddamn
slow but you know once I got over my
five-second temper tantrum I realized
that I actually had a great time there
so I'm gonna come back next time I'm
coming back it's either when Ole Miss or
Mississippi State has a game I'm going
to a [ __ ] game that and I help the
plane out BAM or some [ __ ] like that
Joe finds a Russian I talked about that
no booze 25 days old Billy [ __ ] red
velvet cakes was gonna take a month off
now all of a sudden he thinks he's the
next he's the second coming a sting you
know sting held onto the hair he was
losing the roof and then all of a sudden
he started doing yoga
he started standing on his [ __ ] head
and all that blood went to the top of
his head started feeding the roots
that's what happened maybe mine will
come back fantasy football has taken
over trading cards and all that [ __ ] I
talked about that well I guess it's time
to get on the [ __ ]
with the the booze lineups here all
right these guys booze line up hey Billy
Bullock chops I'm a listener from a
listener from the UK I by the way it's
16 to 3 well you guys already know this
[ __ ]
Dallas playing some good defense
listener from the UK I managed to get to
your show in Manchester and it was
brilliant ah thank you I was nervous
about that show you know all I knew was
this [ __ ] soccer hoodlums from the
80s you know the [ __ ] neo-nazis
falling around man united that's all I
knew I read among the thugs and to me
that was Manchester he said I wanted to
send you my team of drinks but I don't
watch baseball
oh you're batting lineup ok I tried when
I was in New York to watch baseball but
I found it boring same with football
[ __ ] boring
he means soccer here I guess because he
says I only watch for that for the World
Cup I mainly watch rugby league you
watch that seven nation league where if
you come in last you get the wooden
spoon NFL for the Seahawks cricket and
I'm a big fan of f1 dude if you can sit
through [ __ ] cricket you can get
through a baseball game I mean that's
the same thing except cricket last four
[ __ ] five days I decided to send you
my list of drinks as the Formula One
teams I don't really drink that many
neat spirits or whisky so I included
everything else I drink when I want to
get pissed all right leading off he's
got Mercedes his mercedes-benz team for
those you don't watch f1 they're like
the [ __ ] cream of the crop we really
should have batting cleanup but I get
this you're gonna do this more like you
know how they rank football teams the
best of the worst all right IPA beers
yeah I'm one of those guys but I don't
piss people off talking about it my pole
position drink quite happy to drink
these beers all night drink IPAs all
night Jesus Christ it's like drinking of
Thanksgiving dinner each pint is so
[ __ ] I [ __ ] hate they're so
[ __ ] I you know every once in a while
if I just want to have one beer but I
know I'm gonna drink 30 I'll have an IPA
because by the time I'm
with it I'm just like Jesus Christ
enough enough with the [ __ ] hops good
Lord it's like overacting quit bugging
your eyes out of your [ __ ] head I get
it beers supposed to have hops well as
long as you don't drink any of those
stupid beers they'd have those those
aggressive for no reason names you know
angry [ __ ] kick your mother in the
[ __ ] beer whatever they'll have ale
angry Heil all right
his second batter would be the Ferrari
team Jack Daniels black label old number
seven whatever you want to call it been
around for these all these years and
it's and it is as popular as it's always
been
usually drink it with the coke rarely
neat oh Jesus this guy's not even in
triple-a here batting third red bull
mount gate with Mount Gay Eclipse Rum
all right if you're in your 20s I
forgive you for this lineup I've been
drinking it with ginger beer since these
guys were Jaguar all the red ball of
sorry the Red Bull team I'm a [ __ ]
idiot
so I'm sorry I think you're drinking Red
Bulls and Mount Gay Eclipse rum I was
like what in the [ __ ] I'm sorry I
apologize
all right Force India team is is a brow
vodka never heard of that usually with
apple juice do I get mean I'll see you
drink like a woman usually with apple
juice and a little umbrella in there and
I thought it's been around a couple of
times though I like fatness I'm new to
good vodka like a few Brits
I was drinking paint stripper Vaud paint
striper vodka and Red Bull from 17 all
right the Williams Stella
our toys larger it's okay Williams team
is the Stella our toys I don't know how
to say have to [ __ ] the old dependable I
never heard of it but doesn't win many
races anymore
still nothing beats turning up at a
mate's house with the crate of Stella
for a day of drinking Toro Rosso team
would be Sailor Jerry rum this guy's a
rum drinker when I started drinking rum
and moved to the Red Bull team not long
after all right Molly she didn't mix
that with anything
the Hoss the American for
one Jack Daniels single barrel one for
the Americans there you go the only
whiskey I really drink neat good man
there's hope for you Renault
that poor ass team bitter the classic
British British drink which is not
served warm it served its cellular
cellar temperature I don't know what
bitter is McLaren Jagermeister not as
good as it used to be but I have some
great nights drinking this stuff how the
[ __ ] anybody drinks more than one of
those is beyond me the Sauber team I
don't know who that is bringing up the
rear it's cider not even close to a
go-to drink but I'm glad it's there I
[ __ ] hate cider
I love the podcasts f is for family and
all the specials come back to the UK
soon thanks and go [ __ ] yourself I'll
definitely be back there thank you for
your booze line up there was actually a
couple interesting things in there
that's a brow Cup vodka I never heard of
that but you know I'm gonna do yoga and
Pilates for the rest of my life I'm
gonna age like sting granted he started
doing that [ __ ] miss 30s alright number
two alright um question number two or
whatever the [ __ ] I'm doing this week a
rhinestone ball bag Billy I love the
podcast and love when you rip into the
morons simply for being morons keep it
up that's why I trash myself so much I
wanted to throw down a booze line up but
for hockey all right here we go we're
going for more booze Lynam I feel like
this is getting old people I'm gonna
read this last one that's gonna be it
for the booze lineups and every once in
a while we'll do it we need some more
overrated underrated Center the Cyndi
crowd be positioned Miller Genuine Draft
that beer god bless you somebody's got
to drink it you pay a little too much
for him but he's your franchise players
so you have no choice left wing is
Wiser's Black Label smooth dangles and
sets everyone else up right wing is
Santiago 16 year Cuban rum rum foreign
player other teams are afraid to sign
that plays his ass off every night but
take some stupid penalties demon number
1 Jack Daniels safe gritty defensive
minded
and you D and you didn't break the cap
hit for him D man 2 Coors Light never
misses a game jumps up in the zone but
on the wrong end of the odd man rushes
too often goalie is Crown Royal hometown
boy that gives you 65 starts this season
and always gives you a chance bartnik
would love that line up I don't know
about Miller Genuine Draft but he'd love
that you finished with Crown Royal
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself all right
now we're on now we're on to some
[ __ ] questions here all right and the
[ __ ] are we bill what is this this is
more [ __ ] football I can't do this
this is there's too many boos listed
here what's this gonna get boring
because it requires me to really read
out loud which I'm not good at all right
fingerprinting students what in the [ __ ]
is happening to this world hey Billy
Bowl Baggins I'll try to keep this short
I just started college and in the dining
halls they now only use fingerprint
scanners to let you in cooking is not
allowed in the dorms so if you want to
eat you have to give them your
fingerprints I'm not one of those I got
chips slash free t-shirt people but what
else can I do
your thoughts would be appreciated
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself
well Millennials I think it's time you
guys [ __ ] Rebell you got a rebel
against something here I'll go to Subway
why do they need your [ __ ]
fingerprints and what are they gonna do
with them even if they're not gonna do
anything with them they're gonna hack
into your system
somebody's gonna hack into the system
that's so [ __ ] nuts that is legit I
get honest lis have to look up like how
how how do people justify taking your
[ __ ] fingerprints to give you a
[ __ ] slice of pizza
how do colleges justify taking students
fingerprints I love all the mainstream
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass [ __ ] corporate media
never talks about this [ __ ] they do
sell people out they're just such all
these [ __ ] idiots screaming about
Trump and Hillary and this is what
they're doing to citizens of this
[ __ ] country it's [ __ ]
unbelievable can I refuse to have my
child fingerprinted at school background
of fingerprinting I got a Jesus
I almost lied to you guys I got to read
up on this like I'm actually going to do
this should schools fingerprint your
kids
isn't that what is this for let me guess
it's for our own protection all they do
is make gift bags for people that know
how to go on the internet and steal [ __ ]
there it is it's the [ __ ] social
security number with the fingerprints
the home address all the relatives all
in a night and neat nice neat little
[ __ ] bag I can't [ __ ] believe that
this these [ __ ] jerk-offs these
[ __ ] jerk-offs anybody watches Fox
and CNN as a [ __ ] jerk-off when was
the last time they held the feet of the
[ __ ] [ __ ] that are doing all of this
[ __ ] it's in the fire when the [ __ ] are
they ever done that if they ever really
gone off pharmaceutical companies for
starting a heroin epidemic had they ever
really gone after Monsanto for [ __ ]
with the food supply have they ever
really gone after bankers for what the
[ __ ] they were allowed to get away with
ten [ __ ] years ago
jesus [ __ ] christ you do one
off-color [ __ ] joke they cover that
more than these [ __ ] insurance
companies probably gonna [ __ ] everybody
over now I'm upset you know what I would
do sir I would [ __ ] somehow go out of
my own pocket and I would [ __ ] eat
down the street for [ __ ] cheap the
best I could
that's why you can still bring snacks
you can't cook you can still have a
fridge right I need a bowl of [ __ ]
cereal I would eat a [ __ ] bowl of
cereal three days of three times a
[ __ ] day before I get those [ __ ]
[ __ ] you goddamn fingerprints first of
all you all you're gonna do is come out
of college you're gonna be all these
student loans and what sort of job is he
gonna be there you got to give me a
finger
prince2 [ __ ] these people [ __ ] them you
know I don't know you're not even
allowed to [ __ ] protest anymore you'd
have to go to a certain section you'd
have to get a [ __ ] permit to protest
do I guaran-fucking-tee you I guarantee
you the reason why they've taken your
fingerprints is an added revenue stream
and they're going to you know they're
they're gonna [ __ ] sell them to
somebody else all of those [ __ ]
people that take your [ __ ]
information are we digging we need safe
and secure it isn't safe and secure what
they've done now is they've made it a
lot easier for these people that go in
and steal [ __ ] rather than having to
break into you personally they just
break into a company and they get like a
whatever a couple thousand people a
whack and then what kills me is after
these [ __ ] take your information their
system gets hacked into and you can you
sue them for putting your [ __ ] up there
it's [ __ ] unreal anyways I just
recently had you know a TV network that
I worked for sent me a [ __ ] letter
she'd go in there and go read it and say
you know unfortunately someone broke
into our system and a lot of personal
information was might have been exposed
so all they're required to do after it's
like why did you keep all that
information we need to go back to paper
and file cameras people
I'm telling you make these [ __ ]
pieces of [ __ ] put on little cat burglar
outfits have the flashlight in their
mouths as they try to pick the lock to
go in sorry I really just lost my [ __ ]
there but I feel like my you know even
though I didn't have all the information
I needed to make a logical argument I
feel like I am right I'm sniffing around
something there all right Alcoholics
Anonymous hey Bill I was in a a for
roughly two years if you're thinking
about attending I would suggest you
visit a library and get the a a big book
sometimes they have a copy available I
would read it okay now you just asked me
to do two things that are really
difficult for me one going to a library
in to finding a book and then three
three reading it what else you only do
dunk a basketball you really getting
outside the realm of what I do here then
I would also read the orange papers an
online website which attempts to debunk
the a a philosophy attend a few meetings
and get a feel for it but honestly I
don't think you're an alcoholic from
listening to your podcast I just think
you're a pisshead you can put a cork in
the bottle I hear you sometimes beating
yourself up when you've had three large
pores oh jesus relax that's not
alcoholism I love this guy sure you're
probably not a good drinker but it's all
on a spectrum and you seem to be doing
fine when you start drinking cleaning
gel mixed with fruit juice because it
has alcohol in it then we can talk I've
heard it all in a a and and you don't
qualify for the club in my humble
opinion take it easy you bald [ __ ]
alright well thank you for the kind word
sir
no but it's also it's not good for you I
can tell you it's not at the level that
I was drinking was not good for you but
I also don't think a is bad if it works
for you then I think it's good if it
doesn't work for you I don't think you
then have to go out and debunk it what
kind of a [ __ ] doesn't like alcohol and
non alcoholic Anonymous has helped so
many [ __ ] people let me look at the
orange papers the [ __ ] C [ __ ] who
just say everybody just always has to
rain on somebody's parade orange papers
here
I just realized somebody might be
[ __ ] riding out this hurricane down
in Florida listening to this podcast if
you still have power if you get a
generator I just said rain rain on your
[ __ ] parade sorry what are the orange
papers orange papers I spilled orange
wrong I put two ends in there I don't
know why I said oh are na ng orange
papers aaaa here we go
orange papers recovering from recovery
anti AAA sites such as orange papers all
right now this is just gonna be another
website that just hijacked the whole
[ __ ] thing so I can't get to it where
are the
original orange papers original original
please please can I get the original I
can't find it I cannot [ __ ] find what
the [ __ ] come on man I already just
clicked on this page and I see a big
picture of a monkey leaving a a staying
sober all right here we go for some the
suffering alcoholic and those unhappy in
AAA and alright let's see what they
[ __ ] about here for the suffering
alcoholic and those unhappy in AAA
alcoholics Anonymous has over 2 million
participants globally that's it it is a
friendly and welcoming organization with
many carrying helpful members AAA offers
companionship ba ba ba ba ba if you
think you have a drinking problem and
haven't tried AAA stop reading this
essay and go to a meeting however a
growing number of options have slowly
because I don't want to [ __ ] read all
of this [ __ ] alright I'll take your word
for it evidently look at Eli stepping up
in the pocket
what's the score you 16 to 3 7 minutes
to go did he just throw a pick who knows
alright wife working out with ex oh
jesus [ __ ] christ if i saw that at
the beginning of a [ __ ] porno i'd be
like oh my god can we come up with a
[ __ ] less cliched scenario ok hey
there Billy red sack love your podcast
love emphasis for family can't wait for
season 3 I wanted your advice on
something here's the story I got married
about a year ago and me and my lovely
wife moved to LA right after the wedding
because she had a great job opportunity
she had lived in LA a few years ago
prior to meeting me and when she was
living here she had a fling with some
douchey private fitness trainer both of
them viewed marriage as a stupid concept
and they
a pact that when they'll get married to
other people they'd meet up and [ __ ] I
don't believe a [ __ ] word of this I
don't believe a [ __ ] word of this
this is too stupid they made a pact when
when they'll get married to other people
they'd meet up and [ __ ] I mean that
definitely sounds like an L a
conversation in a gym I'll continue
reading so as soon as she changed her
relationship status to married on
Facebook that guy sent her a bunch of
messages which were sexual and pretty
much offender offered to take her up on
the agreement and [ __ ] she didn't
respond but she did tell me about it
but I didn't lose my [ __ ] and remain
calm in the last few weeks she told me
she's looking for a way to get in shape
and she said that the douche had offered
her private workout sessions in exchange
for her help in his business she's an
accountant she said that because private
workout sessions are expensive and he's
very good at what he does this is a
great opportunity that would save us
some money she said she made it clear to
him that she's happily married and
nothing is going to happen and he
understood completely she asked me if it
bothers me and I not wanting to look
like the insecure jealous type oh my god
you [ __ ] dude I'm telling these
[ __ ] women are in guys heads all of
this [ __ ] that you've seen on
[ __ ] TV all of these [ __ ] women
[ __ ] playing the victim all the time
all of this [ __ ] coverage of just
what guys do to women as now every
[ __ ] guy has his balls in his [ __ ]
back pocket and it's just like well I
don't want to be the guy that [ __ ]
makes you uncomfortable but she [ __ ]
tolerate this from you you don't want to
look in so that's not being insecure sir
that's common [ __ ] sense
so he said honestly honey I trust you I
want what's best for you
and tried actually to do that my
question is do you think she's
trustworthy possible but that guy isn't
and that guy's just drawn her in cuz he
wants to [ __ ] her she does have a
history of cheating on her exes but so
do i we've both been happily married and
our sex life is great but still the
doubt and insecurity about that ish this
issue exists love to hear your take on
this can't wait for the new hour special
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself buddy buddy
yet no no no [ __ ] way
no [ __ ] way work some extra hours you
know I would actually be willing to
believe that she's going over there
thinking she's not going to do anything
but that guy's gonna seduce her that's
what's gonna happen
they already banged there already you
know physically like you know you know
the boundaries are not gonna be there
and I'm telling you that's not a good
situation and you're not in you're not
insecure at all you know
and so what if you are that's a
legitimate that's a legitimate feeling
that full [ __ ] thing let's let there's
stupid [ __ ] t-shirts and so this is
some woman was wearing this [ __ ]
t-shirt that I told you about that when
I was back in the summertime said
something like a real man is excited by
a strong woman a boy is like whatever
intimidated or something like that some
mule oh I want to be I want to be
considered as strong man I want a cookie
I was reading that Rolling Stone where
they had the actress that was playing
played Wonder Woman and I was all
excited to read the article in the first
quote that they had they said are you a
feminist she goes yes I'm a feminist
everyone should be a feminist because if
you're not a feminist and you're a
sexist right and I like bursted out
laughing thinking like well it all
depends on what your definition is yeah
that's what's funny about these
Hollywood people out here I swear to god
they sound just like the Fox News right
people
they're the exact you know there is ZERO
tolerance you think the way I do if you
do not then you are this like there's no
clear-cut definition of feminism any
more than there is of like what makes
like that you know that's real rock
music and then somebody's always like
that's not rock did she's rock that's
[ __ ]
it's the same thing with like family
like everyone was a feminist the way my
wife is which you know in all fairness
this actress that played Wonder Woman
could be I don't [ __ ] know but you
sitting like that is just such a I mean
granted it's a [ __ ] interview they're
trying to get people [ __ ] worked up
to read the [ __ ] thing maybe it was
taken out of context maybe she said
others [ __ ] but just the way that's
presented you know rolling stone is just
[ __ ] insufferable though it's just
[ __ ] insufferable the way they
handled Obama with like kid gloves and
if you're a [ __ ] Republican they
stick your head in the fire now I'm not
saying they shouldn't stick these
Republicans head in the fire I mean
they're the [ __ ] you know that
they're bought and paid for at that
level right am i nuts and I also thought
Obama was too judging by the sixty nine
million dollars worth of tour dates he
has coming up giving speeches to all
these [ __ ] rich people guy just
bought a ten million dollar [ __ ]
house
it's [ __ ] unreal and they don't say
[ __ ] all I did was show him playing
highlight and [ __ ] going kayaking and
parasailing like isn't he cool I can't
believe how cool he is anyways
by the way rolling stone is Trump the
worst president ever I haven't noticed
you it's not like you haven't [ __ ]
written it it's just like I don't even
read the [ __ ] article it's like I
understood your point of view the first
ninety articles there's so much other
[ __ ] you could be writing about you
don't I mean good [ __ ] Lord like why
can't you make fun of like extreme
liberals every once in a while throw me
a [ __ ] curve ball something Jesus
Christ I [ __ ] need to go buy some
[ __ ] tampons here I'm sorry you know
what I'm gonna happen you know what the
funny stopped
the fingerprint of these [ __ ] poor
kids these poor kids are going to
college so getting it all in [ __ ]
debt
alright and these colleges are acting
like they've adapted to how quickly the
real world is changing and I don't think
they are and that's why these kids are
coming out it's like they're coming out
with degrees and like [ __ ] I don't
know what [ __ ] churning butter
essentially and then they can't find a
[ __ ] job
you know I don't know I remember like we
always read up about all these [ __ ]
amazing musicians they would go to
Berkeley and they would they would never
complained the guys that went out seeing
the guys that went out and did [ __ ] they
never finished like they were like this
this whole being here I got what I
needed
now I got to get the [ __ ] out of here
and I'm not saying drop out of college
but I really feel like if that voice is
screaming in your head and you [ __ ]
have some good ideas why take on the
last year a debt the less you know why
cuz your parents want you to I don't
know what because Bill Gates dropped out
if you drop out I'm just saying you know
what the [ __ ] I ended up doing I didn't
need to go to college had all those
[ __ ] village student loan all that
debt and I left and I immediately went
down to a comedy club and started doing
[ __ ] jokes anyways we got to end on
something positive here please go to
that Steven Adler Ronnie James think I'm
gonna post that the bowl for Ronnie
Ronnie James what a [ __ ] voice what a
great guy too man I never met the guy
but like all his interviews he could
have been more down-to-earth once again
it's gonna be at pins pinc bowling
center one two six five five Ventura
Boulevard
it's gonna be a bunch of rock stars
they're a bunch of comedians all bowling
raising money for uh I don't even know
what the what is the cause here I know
Ronnie died of cancer so I imagine it's
that right Oh Ronnie Ronnie James Dio
stand up and shout cancer fun there you
go stay right
so there's something positive for you
and I believe it's October 6th all right
I will be tweeting that out and I am
trying to get back onto Instagram I
haven't posted on Instagram and forever
I think I have to create an entirely new
account because I keep saying I forgot
my password please email it to me and
they haven't been able or I haven't been
able I can't find the [ __ ] thing so
that's it that's the podcast for this
week congratulations to everybody one
week one congratulations it's all
football fans that is football season my
favorite [ __ ] thing happened this
weekend by the way when I was in the
Alabama theater there was this [ __ ]
guy in the front row and he had his the
middle-aged - he had his cell phone on
it's middle-aged guy and I'm like dude
he record the show he record the show
and he kind of was like now it goes
because I'm looking at the scores
because it was Saturday night he wanted
to see how the other SEC teams were
doing and I go well what's what what are
you watching he was watching the Georgia
game I go with your Alabama what the
[ __ ] do you give a [ __ ] about Georgia
for he goes there in the SCC I go and
then I kind of catch you I got that
decent quarterback though I don't know
then the crowd kind of dies down and
this guy in the back goes he says to the
guy with the phone he just goes excuse
me sir
sir he goes what he say [ __ ] I'm gonna
put you the joke Auburn Clemson whoever
the [ __ ] iron was playing it was like I
wasn't even there anymore he just asked
for his score oh god what a [ __ ]
great setup it would have been such a
killer story if I could have [ __ ]
remembered Auburn score what do we got
here that's right they played Clemson
yeah he goes excuse me sir Auburn
Clemson that's all he had to say the
guy's just right on his phone looking to
give him the [ __ ] score I don't know
it's a great [ __ ] place don't sleep
on the south all right if you really
think about it you're States just as
racist okay that's it go [ __ ] yourselves
I don't know what else to tell you I'll
check in on you on Thursday I hope you
know I hope there's little damage in
Florida is humanly possible and that's
all you can [ __ ] hope for and you
know all you guys making fun of people
drive an electric
I don't know now you know what the [ __ ]
I Drive gas combustion cars so I'm not
[ __ ] looking down on you but you know
I don't know what the battery does in
the end when you drive the Tesla into
the [ __ ] ocean can you recycle the
battery I have no idea but I'll tell you
what that guys doing over there that
Tesla company I like it I like it I just
wish the car could look a little more
meaner looks great from the back looks
great from the side the front I don't
know what it is just can't quite get
into it but I know it's a [ __ ]
amazing car but they SUVs [ __ ] cool
huh the Lamborghini doors opening up
plus it's also a great way to win the
war in the Middle East you know drive an
electric car you ride a bicycle anything
you do to use less [ __ ] fossil fuels
[ __ ] those people over over there and
they don't have money to funnel through
the mosques to give to the terrorists
and there you go and then all of a
sudden Oh Jimmy crack corn is out of
fireworks right oh I just solved the
Middle Eastern problem or the Middle
East problem not Middle Eastern I don't
have problems with Middle Eastern people
and this is why I don't hold office all
right go [ __ ] yourselves people I'll
talk to you on Thursday